le chef du Parti conservateur revient à
la charge et demande un accès à
l'Assemblée nationale en dépit du fait
qu'il n'est pas encore réussi à faire
élire un député peut-être en faire
changer un de parti de traverser la
chambre on sait jamais c'est déjà arrivé
une fois alors il est quand même ignoré
l'espoir que la prochaine président de
l'Assemblée nationale parce que c'est un
secret de polichinelle que ce serait
Madame Nathalie Roy pour être favorable
ça demande en tout cas le PQ lui a donné
son appui revendication du chef
conservateur alors pour bien connaître
ces revendications c'est mon invité ce
soir bonsoir rituel avec le temps qui
passe vous allez
renoncer à pouvoir
des poser des questions avoir un rôle
parlementaire précisez-nous ce que vous
voulez on a eu 530 000 Québécois qui le
3 octobre ont voté conservateur c'est la
plus grosse distorsion démocratique
d'histoire du Québec il faut le rappeler
le jamais dans l'histoire du Québec un
parti va obtenu plus que 6% des votes et
n'avaient pas eu de députés à
l'Assemblée nationale nous on a fait 13
% et on s'est vraiment ça avec ce
résultat là bon cela étant dit on ne
demande pas un siège à Assemblée
nationale comme le propose par exemple
Jean-François lisier l'ancien chef piqué
son demande pas non plus de poser des
questions de la tribune en haut comme ça
c'est déjà fait au Nouveau-Brunswick ou
ailleurs ce qu'on demande simplement
c'est que je puisse continuer à faire
des points de presse à l'intérieur des
murs de l'Assemblée nationale comme
c'était le cas 23 octobre qu'on puisse
assister quand il y a des budgets ou des
rapports de VG ou de sorte de trucs au
huis clos pour pouvoir réagir comme les
autres partis comme les journalistes
font comme les journalistes aussi et
finalement qu'on puisse avoir un bureau
pour accueillir les groupes de pression
notamment qui viennent à l'Assemblée
nationale rencontrer les Jeff et les
élus
est-ce qu'on vous dit non parce que vous
avez l'appui du Parti québécois
il y a quelques semaines il y a personne
qui m'a dit non j'ai reparlé à tout le
monde et le Parti québécois le fait
publiquement aujourd'hui pour dire
qu'ils étaient d'accord les autres se
sentaient plus à l'aise si je passais
par la présidence parce que ultimement
c'est la prérogative la Présidence de
l'Assemblée nationale l'utilisation des
lieux qui sont faits c'est pour ça que
j'ai rendu public hier la lettre qu'on
va envoyer demain à Madame Nathalie Roy
nouvelle président de l'Assemblée
nationale pour que elle puisse nous
donner accès à ça j'ai même demandé à
l'ancien président de l'Assemblée
nationale Jean-Pierre Charbonneau nous
conseiller à là-dedans puis
effectivement c'est la prérogative
ultime de la Présidence de l'Assemblée
nationale Jean-Pierre Charbonneau qui
rappelons-le sans jamais être parti dans
avec vous
ce
réforme démocratique depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs il organise demain une
manifestation devant l'Assemblée
nationale demain midi le pour dénoncer
la distorsion démocratique qui ont eu
lieu le 3 octobre là dessus et vous
dites ça ne coûterait pas un sou la
question de du fameux critère il faut du
critère il faut un député pour avoir
accès même à ce que vous demandez est-ce
que c'est une règle qui peut être revu
dans le dernier dans la dernière
législature et on nous a donné le droit
de faire des conférences de presse à
tous les deux on avait le droit d'être
parti mais on avait quand même le droit
de nous en tant que non élu de faire des
points de presse on avait le droit
d'aller au huis clos donc on avait droit
d'utiliser les lieux on avait notre
passe d'accès
c'est parti là avait un député le vôtre
quelque chose qui est complètement
ridicule quand vous y pensez madame soul
moi j'avais convaincu une seule femme de
traverser puis joindre le Parti
conservateur du Québec j'avais tous ces
droits là on a convaincu collectivement
530 000 Québécois de voter conservateur
puis on a plus aucun droit ma passe
d'accès a été désactivé je peux même
plus rentrer à l'Assemblée nationale
quel message on envoie quand on veut
augmenter la participation électorale on
est en train de dire à un million de
Québécois votre vote il vaut rien c'est
pour ça que je pense que Madame Roy doit
intervenir alors sur gilba quand on est
en question c'est si le critères actuel
c'est d'avoir au moins un élu sur quelle
base ce critères-là devrait être mis de
côté pour en adopter un autre soit le
pourcentage des voix ou le pourcentage
des voix dans notre cas mais à chaque
élection les critères sont revus vous
savez garder si on avait suivi les
critères très stricts et le Parti
québécois et Québec soldat n'aurait pas
eu les droits qui se qu'on leur a donné
au cours des derniers jours ça a été le
même chose quand j'étais à la DQ c'était
la même chose après chaque élection en
fonction du résultat les parlementaires
les partis ça soit ils écoutent on va
faire une des aménagements parce que il
y a une distorsion démocratique qui a eu
lieu qu'on veut s'assurer que la voix
d'un plus grand nombre de Québécois soit
entendu à la Maison du Peuple la Maison
du Peuple c'est pas dire à un électeur
sur 7 ou 8 rester dehors on veut même
pas vous ayez droit de rentrer en même
temps cette distorsion là est en raison
du mode de scrutin qui devrait être
formé si je ne m'abuse vous prenez pas
position là-dessus vous l'avez pas fait
pendant la campagne électorale pas
encore mais ce que je veux faire
d'ailleurs demain je vais faire un live
justement avec Jean-Pierre Charbonneau
ses réseaux sociaux mais soit mais je
veux je veux qu'au prochain congrin
puisse en discuter on a pas eu le temps
de déborder cette question là sur mon
leadership je veux qu'il y a une
discussion franche et ouverte je vais
avoir une légitimité démocratique pour
défendre une réforme de scrutin ou non
il y a des pots et des comptes le
réforme de mode de soutien moi le
problème que j'ai actuellement c'est que
je ne vois pas comment on peut le faire
à court terme on a partout pouvoir et le
position officiel c'est on est plus loin
d'une réforme démocratique qu'on n'a
jamais été parce qu'on a autant le parti
pouvoir que le position officiel qui va
le rien savoir donc l'impression que
c'est pas très réaliste en fait qui sont
qui sont cons
la cacahuète un engagement solonel
monsieur le gars avait signé si la
claque avait tenu parole il y aurait pas
0 député à l'Assemblée nationale il y en
aurait dix et du Canada qui a fait les
calculs on serait 10 aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale mais monsieur Lego
m'a répondu à l'émission 5 chefs une
élection que c'est un affaire
d'intellectuel s'intéressait personne
les autobus mais aujourd'hui peut-être
que ces intéresse pas parce qu'ils ont
90 conservateurs ces intéresse je pense
pas qu'on est tous des intellectuels
madame parce que en version des règles
électorales vous pouvez quand même avoir
beaucoup d'argent vous allez avoir
combien un milliards
je pense par vote mais
mais les budgets de l'Assemblée
nationale sont n'a rien libérant plus
que 5 millions le y a eu à partir de
même nombre de votes que nous ils vont
avoir plus de 5 millions puis nous
autres on a zéro c'est ça aussi la
distorsion moi je demande même pas de
l'argent c'est un conservateur fiscal on
ira pas là mais les valeurs puisent dit
qu'on défende vous le savez mieux que
n'importe qui madame monsieur sont très
différentes des autres parties
le groupe d'intérêt de nous un parti
politique je veux que ça se fasse là où
le la Maison du peuple est supposé
représenté l'ensemble de la population
québécoise il y a quelque chose de très
symbolique deuxièmement quand on est à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est tout ça on
dirait que les médias peuvent nous
suivre en direct même les gens peuvent
nous suivre à la maison en direct il y a
aussi des avantages d'être à l'intérieur
des murs de l'Assemblée je pense que
c'est il faut envoyer le symbole clair
au Québec on est ouvert puis il y a pas
c'est pas vrai qu'on va prendre un
électeur sur 7 ou sur 8 donc traverse la
rue votre temps de l'autre barre est un
pariotte pas bien venu en Maison du
Peuple c'est c'est complètement
inacceptable puis ça ça transcende des
lignes de partie vous savez que
Françoise David m'a appuyer au cours des
derniers jours c'est pas parce que
effectivement
vos alliés sont des gens défend on verra
les résultats qu'est-ce que ça planait
c'est consulat multiplier les appuis
continuent à mettre la pression il va
falloir continuer à dire que s'il y a
quelque chose de totalement démocratique
puis c'est jamais fini tant que c'est
fini on va continuer à se battre merci
beaucoup c'est moi qui vous remercie
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI